[NO SPEECH]
TAKAKO AIKAWA: So we have
the daily grade system.
This is so students are
supposed to practice, you know,
online exercises by
themselves before the class.
And then-- so we grade their
performance in class based--
and then based on
their performance,
like the best performance is
going to be graded like 10.10.
And then if students
just come to class
without any preparation, they
may get either six or seven
depending on the instructor.
So daily grade system
is a great incentive
for students to practice
outside of the class
or before the class.
So we had so-called interview
test twice for each semester.
And what we do is actually
one to one kind of interview
setting, usually, like, five
to seven minutes, again,
depending on the level.
That-- what we do as teachers
kind of elicit some questions
so that student can
answer, you know,
particular forms and
grammar patterns.
So, the interview test, we
do like five to seven minutes
for each student.
If you have like 50 students,
having interview test
itself is actually
a lot of work.
We usually spend one day,
sometimes two days, actually.
We like to give individually
feedback on their performance,
but that itself, again,
additional, like,
two to three days,
we cannot afford it.
So we usually get
just a point, not--
and then if there are some,
you know, specific issues,
say, like, you know,
some students are not
good at pronouncing
particular words,
and then we provide
specific feedback.
Otherwise, usually
we just spend--
we just give the point.